it's a fool a Capcom exclusive our 98.3
where hip-hop lives man bootleg Kevin
here and we have got one of the hottest
wrestlers in the world right now this
guy is definitely the strongest wrestler
and most visually intimidating wrestler
I can remember in some second we got
right Ryback in the building once I
managed oh no man though you ever have
them
yes sir I'm a big fan of your run
recently man you you of course were
always that dude was beating the hell
out of jabbers for a while yeah that was
my calling for a while yeah you were
just mopping up nobodies and you know 25
seconds and then you you you got thrown
into this feud with CM Punk recently and
Helena saw happen yeah they kind of
jumped up quick and they able to well
and it's been an amazing ride so far but
things last see ones have really really
taken off of everything I was gonna ask
you how enemy of course I know you've
been working a long time to get to this
point you thought you were an NXT before
that you you know work you know
wrestling on a developmental contract
now that you're like a star you know now
you're a superstar what's it like to
finally you know reach something to him
few people do you know it's it's an
amazing feeling and it's to work your
whole life for something and to have a
lot of people tell you that you're not
gonna do it and then to know deep down
that you're gonna do it right don't know
when and for it to finally happen
there's no feeling in the world like
it's now um did John Cena I know he got
injured and that would that have
something to do with with kind of your
acceleration into the main part yeah
definitely sometimes you know with the
WWE the the things the best things
aren't planned out right he went down
with an injury and there was a slot open
and the WWE they threw me in there I
yeah I remember that
that Monday Night Raw were CM Punk head
he was messing up mankind yeah it ended
with you waiting like sitting there and
I was like oh they're about to give
Ryback that push finally and I'm ready
I've been
ready for a long time but it's the
opportunities like this don't come along
very often right like I said very
thankful that it came along what it did
and you know three years ago had it
happened it may not have been ready but
now I'm mentally and physically ready
for this position and I'm here to be
number one there it is man
I noticed recently when you first
started even when you first got into
like you know the mix credit for the for
the WWE chip against the apartment yeah
you didn't really have like you were
almost like you just had your lines that
you would say and you wouldn't get a lot
like you wouldn't say much else you were
still kind of like a mystery on the
minds recently I noticed even though
just a little bit they kind of let you
open up more as far as you know your
dialogue and stuff is um that's
something that you know you're looking
forward to continue to bring you know
more as a character on the mic yeah
definitely where we started at the very
you know ground zero with Ryback and we
were building layers on that and there's
a lot to me you don't give everybody
everything at once
right and I'm of my inner ring persona
it takes speaks for itself
well I did I don't need to say a lot
necessarily but I enjoy speaking I enjoy
doing promos and whatnot but it just
wasn't the right time for it but as of
late they've let me speak a little bit
more and I look forward to the
opportunities because it's like I said
nothing gets to me and it's I think
that's the way you connect with the
audience
he is my thing I think so yeah so I
think things are only gonna get higher
for me once I'm allowed to speak um I
know when I first saw you I know that
this is probably something that you've
definitely heard there's comparisons oh
always right from what I remember I saw
you at one event I remember which one
but there were some people yelling it in
the crowd yeah you know what I was kind
of low-key that was kind of glad you
lost hell in the cell because it kind of
like push that to the side and I think
at first I thought that they were gonna
try to kind of put you on that same kind
of run where you weren't going to shows
what did you think about those
comparisons you guys of course are both
balls in all three years you know
there's big traps and it's easy to
compare I've said this in a lot of
different interviews
you know being a fan myself when I was
growing up and I see a guy that reminded
me of somebody else that I liked you
kind of instantly kind of don't like a
guy and then it takes time do you got a
so I knew that you know go over get his
loyal followers and I just had to keep
going out and doing my thing because I
know I'm a lot different than him yeah
we have our similarities Rybak is a
whole completely different entity than
Goldberg indi and as you've seen as time
has gone on those chants of stop pretty
much yeah every once in a while we'll
still get them here and there but like
they've never bothered me it's better
for the crowd to be chanting something
than nothing you know nothing at all and
I got I got things from the very
beginning so that was good and you know
now if they ever start to feed me more
chants drown them right out and recently
on live events people if they try to do
it Rybak chants thrown about so it's uh
I'm on my way I just gotta keep going
one day at a time and you know it's
gonna be good but when you do the
shellshocked move man I remember I
forgot who you were you arresting
somebody a couple you know
jabbers yeah fine mogul athletes yes
fine local athletes that are trying to
you know definitely get to your position
one day I saw you you you shall shock
like two people at once yeah man
do you ever like pull a muscle I just
sometimes I look at your face and you do
it I'm like man he looks like you know
that that one might be a little hard to
pull off ya know I
and then the weights of those guys you
know it got up of him to have used to
that I did were about 400 and I think 40
pounds it was primo and Epico
yeah I think we're like 420 430 447
everyone along the lines of that but uh
and I've actually got picked up guys
that were like 550 total weight but it's
when you're out there yeah it's
definitely it's the Adrenaline's going
it's it's not easy but I remember I was
in the back one day and a hunter Triple
H II said to music thing you pick up two
guys for your finish sure why not try
and and sure enough I was able it was
actually the best thing that ever
happened that really helped kind of get
people's attention definitely I think
that the finishing move is such an
important component to any superstar yes
I think yours it's like so unique just
because of your strength not a lot of
people could do with
like I was wondering as a fan those
types of moves I get for the finishers
who comes up with those is that
something that you have input in or
animation with all this is a pretty boy
do you know Triple H has helped me
greatly Michael Hayes Arn Anderson
William Regal those have been the kind
of like-minded my circle of guys that I
I keep around me at all times so but
that move I actually came up with Brock
Lesnar used to kind of do a fisherman
suplex okay and I kind of got the idea
for that that March around at the end
and the whole shot battle fatigue -
Armand ship in there marching around
with them on your back you know so it is
because people that's what people
remember you know it's not just all
about the move so that's kind of like my
last you know my victory dogs indeed
indeed
now we're humble man this is you know
second biggest event of the year of
course next to my personal favorite - it
is mine as well actually um and it
honestly is shaping up to possibly be
one of the greatest ever yeah it's gonna
be a unbelievable you're of course it's
being thrown around that yourself
Johnson are the two names I hear the
most is probably you know everyone's
thinking it's gonna pull out a Royal
Rumble
well yeah you haven't been a part of our
you require I know this is my first
Royal Rumble actually yes so you know
John us a few under his belt as some of
the other guys do but I was built for
this sort of thing I think so I think of
course I think I think going into it if
you're a betting man you got to go ride
back on the lunar Rumble I think you can
outlast I look forward I think it'd be a
pretty cool moment just a little bit any
guy after guy screaming feed me more
right and just getting rid of guy at the
bodies one into awesome we also have our
fan fest on Saturday and wait yeah 12:00
noon tickets are $10 and everyone can
come out they're gonna be there I'm
gonna be there during the day and at
night also all your favorite may be W
superstars divas and past legends along
we're gonna have a tournament also for a
spot in the Royal Rumble oh wow
so yeah now that they're not gonna win
it but of course then if there's my kid
knocked out by you yeah so that's
something that they added there'll be
food and drinks and everything and
entertainment so it's gonna be good
times yeah good time very got a family
you know hey with yourself you know like
I felt like for a while there the stars
in the WB we're not necessarily entail
what I thought there wasn't a lot of new
talent was being pet but recently with
like yourself and Joe Cesaro San Antonio
Cesaro the CEO the shield you know it's
been very refreshing who is somebody who
you're personally a fan of but you think
you know it should get that next push
that's you know what we Baron is uh we
go back you know to the Nexus of
everything I think he's gonna be you
know a major player for years I think so
too
I'm glad to have my back up the banner
kind oh yeah he's on his way back he's
he's working his way back up you know he
was out with an injury for a while and
he's personally one of my favorites
Daniel Bryan he's already but he's yeah
Daniel my personal favorite there's not
a lot of people that that motivate me he
motivates me he like that guy works hard
you know I work hard but like he just
does different things I can learn if he
doesn't eat meat yeah I actually
recently had to give up meat myself oh
you did right Mac doesn't eat meat after
him innocence by not by choice it's by
my doctor we filmed a Christmas special
thing where they had me scream I can't
eat enough red meat yeah yeah of course
and uh right after we filmed that by I
got my cholesterol levels back for my
doctor and they were sky-high and I was
eating meat about six to eight times a
day yeah literally like since I'm good
an adult and my cholesterol has always
been high but now it's out of control so
I was forced to completely cut it out of
my what are you supplement now a turkey
fish and uh like try to think it's
mostly chicken turkey and fish oh man
yeah that's breaking the news right back
mr. feed me more is not eating red meat
anymore
I've actually leaned up a little bit
more since I probably dropped like five
to seven pounds from quitting me that's
what so I feel good now you know what
I'm looking forward to if it ever
happens in the future of big e langston
and Ryback match yeah no biggie is he is
one of the strongest guys but you guys
to me you guys are both like when you
see you you know I saw Big E Langston
and that's the first thing I thought I
was like wow yeah if he got into it with
Ryback so bad being that'd be pretty
amazing he is he is a specimen and he
I'm a little taller than him though I'll
get that in there but he's physically a
very imposing figure
yeah so that's definitely a matchup of
the years to come that that's gonna
happen that's what's up man way I
appreciate you coming through I'm a big
fan of your character and I really ain't
good luck I hope you I hope you win Rome
thank you very much I look forward to
swimming for you
Phoebe more here these new Mars throwing
throwing a bunch of people out the ring
man it's going down and fan fest is
tomorrow so everyone go check them out
and are you on Twitter I am on Twitter
at Ryback 22 now do you like you have to
tweet in Ryback character
I don't tweet a lot out there I think I
have five tweets and to redo they all
say feed me more they all they're very
simple and basic and I don't as time
goes on all to be more but I'm not I'm
not huge on it but I understand it and
it is good for our fans and to people to
have access to you and everything so
that's what I am on there
all right well hit them on Twitter and
hey thanks for coming through man I
appreciate you thank you very much
Ryback WWE Royal Rumble Sunday be there